foreign
[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down so um I have decided on the
Channel that I am going to be doing a
series where I bring in male
self-improvement coaches
um so welcome to the show introduce
yourself to the people probably I'm
Faisal I'm a men's life coach I help
guys with confidence Charisma around
dating and I'm also a nice guy recovery
specialist a nice guy recovery
specialist I know there's a there's a
thing called the nice guy syndrome are
you saying women don't like nice guys
nice guys finish last what I thought
they don't finish first they know
that that was the thing that you know
when I was growing up I thought you know
what you know being a nice guy
that's the thing that gets the the
relationship story right
right what a lie I was told what okay so
tell me when did you discover that this
was a lie like what was dating like for
you when you were younger so I grew up
as a tech nerd okay so I I spent a lot
of time with computers learning the
language of data the rather than
language of love so
I kind of coasted through life and I I
accidentally had a girlfriend this was
about when I was about 18 19. and that
was a six-year toxic relationship that
last that should have lasted only a
couple of months
but I did a nice guy thing I thought you
know what if I'm just nice if I'm good
in this relationship I get better and
better and better
but it just got worse and worse and
worse I just find myself walking on
eggshells all the time how did I'm
curious how did that last six years
because you seem like a logical guy and
I'm assuming if you were attacked like
if you were you described yourself as
more nerdy yeah yeah I'd imagine like
usually the nerdy guys are pretty
logical it's like why did you think it
would get better if it kept getting
worse well this is the thing about
relationships it's kind of intuitive you
think you know what if I please uh did
more things to make her happy eventually
I'll have a problem-free Smooth Life
so I became the Yes man whatever you
want I will do
and yeah that didn't work and it was
very difficult to leave the relationship
because every time I wanted to leave the
relationship
my nice guy tendency used to come out I
used to get really uncomfortable and I
thought what I'd rather stay in the
relationship because it's less painful
than trying to come out the relationship
and what what happened next was there
another girl
So eventually string well it took six
years to come out of this relationship I
hit a breaking point I thought you know
I have to I can't do this anymore
so I left and I told her you know I
can't do this anymore my family was you
know pleased because they want to happy
they saw me just lose all my spirit
I became very sad and you know just uh
kind of lost myself
so when I came out the relationship and
she used to say to me
if you leave
I'll commit suicide
and it'll be your fault
and that's what kept me in the
relationship
because you know when you're 20 20 years
old you're young and the last thing I
wanted to be was have like blood on my
hands I thought I don't want to do this
I don't be responsible for someone
taking their life
so I'll just stay in this relationship
and do whatever I can to make it work
so um
that's so manipulative for to say that
she would commit suicide yeah
if I lift if I left yeah yeah it was
super native I didn't understand she
sounds like a narcissist it was when I
learned when I started to learn more
about you know human behavior then I
learned that she had real you know
borderline personality kind of disorder
those Tendencies narcissistic Tendencies
so I was really trapped in that
relationship
and what are what are the red flags of a
narcissist like a woman that has those
sort of Tendencies is there anything
that like men can spot early well one of
the things that happened was that she
became
no I love bombing and so love bombing so
whereas she wanted to see my she wanted
my attention all the time
and then she would monitor what I I
would do so she would control what I
would do if I she did some if I did
something
she didn't want me to see my friends so
one of those classic sign is that she
started to isolate myself
so she isolated me from my for my
network and eventually my family
so she would control that aspect part of
me and then she said you know you don't
need to go and see your friends why
don't we go out together
and then she started to slowly
you know worm herself into into a real
controlling way
and you know I put my hand up I was weak
I was very very weak man
so who did you date next
you mentioned you were you were together
with someone for like 10 years yeah so I
had a break
um so I came out of the relationship and
then
I discovered that she didn't really she
didn't commit suicide two weeks after I
broke up she was on holiday with her
friends
I thought wow she recovered quickly
and then then I spent a year on my own
and didn't really date and then I met uh
this girl at work and from there we just
started getting to know each other and
from that
we decided to get together and then we
got married
okay and you were with her for how long
so we were together in total 10 years
and then nine years married and was it a
similar type of relationship dynamic or
was it different no it was different it
was different she was a lot more secure
than I was you know I find myself
behaving in emotionally immature way so
I kind of find how my first ex was
behaving I find myself behaving in a
similar way
which was I liked myself in that and it
was very difficult in the relationship
because she was quite secure
so she she was a lot emotionally mature
than I was I found myself being very
emotional in the relationship I found
myself being very weak in the
relationship
and then my Tendencies of controlling
started to come out my Tendencies of
jealousy started to come out and it I
started really to feel not myself
anymore
so that was difficult
because you picked up all the habits
from your last relationship well I guess
I picked up some of the habits but then
I think there were some parts of me that
hadn't
you know as a
as a human I hadn't matured or developed
so I'd you know later on find out I had
huge environment issues
huge what abandonment issues oh
abandonment issues yeah
did you not have both parents in your
life or what so my parents had problems
with their relationship
my mum struggled with mental health
conditions
and uh so she suffered with paranoid
schizophrenia
she had depression
so I can remember when I was seven years
old
um
try and do everything to save mum
and my dad was a nice guy yeah he was a
really amazing guy but he had the nice
guy Tendencies he was very soft very
gentle he had no backbone no leadership
skills and he didn't really give me the
kind of guidance to become a man so I
grew up in a very feminine kind of
household you know I have a sister I had
cousins all females so I learned a lot
of the feminine kind of narrative so
that was that was a struggle to
um that wasn't a great
foundation for relationships
so you didn't really have like a
masculine role model no so how did a
father who was very kind very generous
very loving but I didn't have a
masculine control role model
um okay so when did you realize that
being the nice guy wasn't the way to go
so it happened so when she told me you
know she's leaving me
your wife yeah so we had two kids so
there were two and five years old that
broke my world that that was the most
difficult time in my life even though I
lost my parents I lost my mom at 19 then
my dad at 30. but
learning that I was going to lose my
ex-wife my wife and my kids would no
longer with the family unit that just
broke I I completely crumbled
and I remember you know just falling to
my knees when I heard that
and there was a part of me
I don't know where I got this from
but there's a part of there's like a
feeling inside was you either go right
or you go left
and it says if you go if you go left
you'll get angry
and you'll fight
if you're right you'll accept everything
and take full responsibility
and when the second he just went towards
right so I'm going to take full
responsibility
so I just I was on my knees I had tears
coming down
knowing that you know I'm not gonna be
around with my kids anymore as much
and I said well this is day one
it's time to wake up
so I remember the saying it says you
know the universe is shaking you to
awaken you
and is that where you found you
mentioned a book No More Mr Nice Guy is
that where like how did you get from
that to where you are now so I remember
I was sitting having lunch with a friend
of mine and he started talking about
psychology
and I I thought wow this is pretty
amazing and I started learning about
human behavior and what it taught me was
that you don't have to be on autopilot
you can
choose your life make decisions based on
what you want
so I decided to delve into psychology I
started getting books after books going
onto the internet learning about
human behavior and then I started
learning about relationships because I
was so hurt I wanted to find out what
did I do wrong
how did I mess up why did I mess up I
don't want to mess up in the future
so I just delved into a lot of books and
that's
um I learned about masculine and
feminine
so I discovered about oh okay so I grew
up
very much a feminine kind of guy I had a
lot of feminine Tendencies I felt a lot
of Shame around that
and then can you give me an example well
so for example
I used to focus a lot on the
relationship think about the
relationship a lot right and that's more
of a feminine okay yeah so I was
thinking about relationship I fantasized
about the relationship have magical
thinking around relationship
and relationship played a huge part if
it wasn't sorted out I wouldn't be okay
and I find myself being indecisive
you know when you say what do you want
I'll be like I don't know what do you
want
and I really learned how frustrating
that is to a woman right that is yeah
so you know I decided um
that I had to do something about this so
Psychology was like a savior it gave me
some answers
and then I just delved into seminars and
books and and then I came across men's
work
and then I came across this book called
number Mr Nice Guy I thought wow what a
provocative title and then I read
through the number Mr Nice Guy and uh
I got really annoyed
because everything in the book was like
this guy knows me he's been following me
around how dare he knows about you know
like what was going on behind closed
doors so that was a real Awakening
and so can
like what what was he saying like what
spoke out to you so nice guys uh they
present a real nice front
but behind closed doors it's a different
story The the world is chaotic
uh the weak
the the big people Pleasers they seek
approval
these were like a lot of big things that
in my life
you know what surprises me because is it
um you said you're from Pakistan I don't
know if we said in the interview but you
said yeah isn't that a more traditional
background
it is it is but it's also a very
um
a meshed background okay so because
when I was growing up there wasn't very
strong men in in our family
and a lot of the times the kind of like
women emotionally ran the show so the
guys were very weak but yeah there is a
traditional kind of aspect to it but
what I found was that women kind of ran
the show
a lot of the guys were enmeshed so they
had like a real deep mum and son
kind of bond has it always been like
that there
I'm working with a lot of guys from
Pakistan from India from from places
like that and I I don't see that a lot
really yeah I'm surprised because we
always talk about like the downfall of
the West so I'm really surprised you're
seeing a lot of the same issues there
too it is because there's so much about
we've got to please Mom
that's so true I do hear that even from
traditional right whatever you do if you
move you know you're not gonna move out
a house if you do move a house mom's
gonna come with you or you're gonna stay
with Mom Mom's like the central focal
point so that then builds a lot of uh
entanglement and binds to Mom so I see
that a lot in the guys
um okay so tell me more about the book
so the book basically was saying women
are never happy is that the it's trying
to please yeah
it's more about like you can do no
matter what you do
you will never the nice guy the guy the
nice guy wants to get to a problem-free
Smooth Life
and that's where we want to get to
because most of the nice guys have like
four fractures I call them the first
fracture is like a nervous system
fracture so they're anxious they're
nervous and if they see Mom upset or
they see their partner upset they're
upset
so this is like a huge co-dependency and
enmeshment really yeah
um okay so it's a bit like you know
happy life happy wife yeah yeah if she's
happy I'm happy if she's sad I'm sad so
this boy oh that's so interesting so
these guys grow up
thinking they have to please their
mother and so it like would teach like
it would teach you essentially that you
always have to please women in order to
have like a happy okay yeah because when
when I started discovering this
um kind of world I had I had you know
hide coaches and mentors to help me
through this and I remember I had a
coach and he said all right it's time
for you to become a man
I'm like I'm in my late 30s I'm a man he
says no psychologically he's still a boy
so what you need to go through is a
process of initiation where you go from
boy to man I said okay what does that
include
and this is one of the things that
includes is you've got to separate from
Mama
I'm like well she died nearly 20 years
ago
he said yeah but psychologically she's
there
I said how does that work out because
there's an invisible bind and the
invisible bind is that you know you will
never be able to love another woman
until you separate from Mom
because whatever you do you'll always
want to please mother
so how do you do that
so it's the process of for men is they
will start to individualize so a lot of
guys that you can know that still are
meshed will
you must come across this ask a man what
do you want
what do they normally say
what are what do they want like from
women yeah just for women just from Life
Food sex food advice but in life what do
they want and what kind of woman do you
want mm-hmm most guys like I don't know
right that's true actually I think a lot
of guys have never been around like a
truly feminine woman especially in the
west I think like a lot of guys have
never experienced it
yeah I agree and even even the women
that they experience in my culture a lot
of women were quite
they were dominant but emotionally very
dominant
so they would get
if they were annoyed or angry or pissed
off the the engulfment of emotions will
come there
and they were like don't upset mother
whatever you do just don't upset mum
okay just keep the peace
can you explain the emotionally dominant
like what is what does that mean like in
a conversation like if she's upset then
everyone's upset is that what you mean
yeah if she's upset then everybody upset
if this if this uh if her mood is down
so everybody else's mood you know
follows her kind of mood
whereas if you're an individualized guy
so when I started going on my recovery
then what would happen is her mood is
her mood it's her responsibility not
mine
so I would take on her responsibility
I'll take on the responsibility or all
right I've got to fix this so my fixer
nice guy tendency comes out okay she's
upset I've got to fix this situation
I've got to sort it out it's my
responsibility
but as a child when you're thinking that
because you know as a child as a as a
guy I'm a Problem Solver I'm naturally a
problem solver so I'm going there trying
to solve this problem
but it's not working
I can't fix our moods I can't fix it so
that's
the kind of the battle I have for the
rest of my life okay so then how how did
you detach I still don't understand how
you attach because to me it's like she'd
been dead 20 years yeah so when so when
when you're a child when your baby your
child you you know you're in her womb so
you kind of like learn to attach with
her nervous system
so she she's caretaking you for you know
from infancy
so when she's caretaking you that's the
kind of like emotional emotions that you
experience so you will experience our
highs our lows and then when you're
experiencing highs and lows you you will
naturally become attuned to that
so I did I've seen guys I completely
detached from emotions or they're over
attached to emotions so the nice guys
are the soft guys ever feminize guys
they're very attached to the human to
her emotions which is why a happy wife
happy life
and and that happens at a very young age
I remember when I was seven years old
and I remember
coming
um
back from school
um and I saw my mom very depressed and
where he sat
so when I came back and I thought okay I
need to fix this because she's sad and
it's not a nice thing for her to
experience
so I tried to geography make a laugh I
tried to do so many things but nothing
worked I did this for years
and I felt really [__] about myself I
thought well I'm useless
I can't fix this I can't resolve this
problem there's something wrong with me
then
so what was the next step
individualizing so when I got a lot of
support
I had to then separate and understand
and then rationalize the fact that if
I'm talking to a girl
and any point she either rejects me says
anything that I don't like or says makes
a comment about me is not to take it
personally
and and to separate that because in a
traditional household
there's a really good book on this it's
called married to Mom by Dr Kenneth
Davis
and he talks about the role of the male
and the female father and and mother is
that mother and
father keep
the father draws a boundary around
himself and Mom and the kids so the kids
know that there's a there's a clear
boundary
so what happens is when Mom is upset or
mum goes through some emotional
challenges in our life she seeks the
help of her husband and not the kids and
not the kids
so now all the moms are going to the
children yes and the children become
it like messes them up because they're
not supposed to mess they're not like
those are adult problems they can't
really fix them absolutely so they
become the surrogate husband or the
partner
wow
that's so interesting because I know so
many kids that like their mom would talk
bad about their dad to them yeah so
that's like a perfect example because
she should be going to her husband about
it and instead she's going to the kids
yeah wow
so a strong father wouldn't normally
have a boundary in saying if there's a
problem you come and see me we deal with
the situation
so she has just a flux of emotions and
then she would you know like I remember
my mom
and I say with my clients all the time
you know they she would uh engulf them
with her emotions because
what I learned as a guy is like you can
absorb the emotions but let it go it
kind of goes around you
whereas if only a child it goes into you
so then you start your emotional Center
Becomes Her emotional Center
so you're not individualized anymore so
when you go on a date when you're older
if she's upset because your emotional
Center isn't linked to you it's linked
to the other person
so how would you fix that
separating are you still fit like could
you fix it because I'm thinking like if
you're in your 30s you've been doing one
thing for 30 years it can't just be like
it goes away like that no so it takes
between uh Dr Kenneth said it takes a
lot of support and it takes between two
years to five years to start separating
so even even now I can you know I can
like even now I can be sitting here and
if you unconsciously had a reaction to
me my unconscious will pick that up then
I ought to have to cognit logically
think okay this is Pearl's uh reaction
it's not my reaction and her reaction is
it's her right
and it's it's for her to manage this I
don't have to get involved
so and and like just it's it's teaching
yourself not to care what people think
in a way it's teaching it's teaching how
to attach yourself to that okay
so when you not attached to that then
you can be a better support because if
you're if I attach to your emotions and
you're upset then it sends me into my
um
hyper Vigilant mode it sets me into an
emergency mode I'm in more panic mode so
I can't be irrational and supportive I'm
more panicked and I'm worried about okay
we need to fix this rather than to be
supportive
and this is one of the problems that I
see a lot of nice guys do is when she's
upset they panic they're like okay we
gotta fix this we've got to fix this
rather than
okay well she's upset that's okay
um
but I can be there as the anchor rather
than wave if she's feeling the emotion
of the Waves he becomes the waves as
well
so he becomes more feminized because
he's trying to yeah
I can think of so many people that this
like
yeah that's that's that's really common
is is so common yeah yeah this is
co-dependency and measurement thread is
very deep rooted well and how does the
dad even know that's going on because
I'm thinking if he's working more than
the mom How would how would he even know
that the mom is dumping her problems
onto the kids
that's a good question I guess um
they would have to have a real strong
bond they'd have to have a real strong
bond and I guess this is where
communication would have that you know
any kind of issues that you have it's
between you and I and and you can
observe the um
you can observe them I remember my son
my son's I've got two boys and they're
like typical boys they love play
fighting they love wrestling with each
other they love wrestling with a uh you
know me and I remember we were walking
back
and this is when I started learning
about like separating like how boys
behave
and so we were walking back and the boys
were like really roughly and tumbling
with each other and then she's like Mom
was like no stop doing that that's
really dangerous and she was getting
really panicked but I and and because
they were walking along the footpath
I knew they were safe because I had my
eyes on them I knew they were safe but
mum was panicking so what was mum was
doing was she was panicking she needed
she needed her reassurance of safety
because she needed safety
she was trying to get safety from the
guys
so what I noticed I'm like okay I got
this situation
they're okay I'm watching them
so then her safety went away from the
guys and then I reassured her
instead of like playing into her
emotions yeah that's like they're fine
I've got it I can see I'm Vigilant I
know what's happening at any point it's
dangerous I will step in
then she could just back down and just
kind of going back into her family
so then what was the next step for you
so you had
get rid of the attachment right yeah
you're saying it right yeah yeah
that was yeah you had to keep
reprogramming your head to or your your
mind to say to basically not care what
people think in a way but not not be
attached to other people's emotions yeah
to take to take it rationally rather
than emotionally okay so I would see
their emotions and I'm like okay well
that's their emotions and you'll see
that in every single culture you'll see
that in everything good and you'll see
that more in cultures that are really
connected to each other because the the
show a lot of codependency okay so one
of the things that I started to learn
was that building my own habits because
you'll see a lot of codependent people
first thing they do in the morning is
what do most people do first thing in
the morning when they get up
yeah
before they eat brush your teeth what
what do most people do in the morning
first thing you gotta bring about you
stretch yourself and then you do
something first thing in the morning
most people do I don't know what
pick up their phone
oh yes yeah that should have been my
first thing yeah yeah I had to pick up
their phone right so what they're doing
is they're prioritizing the outside
world before they prioritize their inner
world
wow that's so interesting
I do that that's what I do in the
morning most people do I do I used to do
that okay so my coach is Mentor suddenly
we want to get over
the the whole point of view individual
individualizing as a man is to become
internal rather than external so you
have to do everything to be internal
because then you'll start validating for
maternal you'll start getting approval
from Italian that's what the masculine
is so you want to go inwards
more than outwards because when you're
outwards
you know you seek validation you have
out of confidence then rather than inner
confidence this is why you know I want
the Lamborghinis I want the Ferraris I
want the five-star hotels because the
external is validating you rather than
the internal is
so that was a process I had to get
internal so I started building habits
I started with a painful habit which was
finishing my shower with the cold shower
okay so that's like for five years I
still hate it
you
do a cold shower yeah so I'll have my
hot shower first okay and now finish off
with a cold shower it's freezing cold I
hate it I'm like I wasn't born in places
like that I'm like oh okay so that so
every day I do something that has to
push me
so everybody so the masculine
grows through challenge
so how to get uh so I started with a
cold shower
and I started this happened winter
probably not the best time but I started
with a culture then I started stacking
up other habits
and when I started psyching up Habits
Like no fun like first thing in the
morning no phone for one hour okay and
then I have a 10 pm rule if I'm at home
at 10 pm my phone goes off even if I'm
talking to a girl even if it's like racy
text messages going on even if it's like
oh you know she's really turned on I'm
like right 10 o'clock you've got to
finish yourself off I'm done so I
started building a lot of uh strong
habits
uh journaling
uh cold shower and no phone use very
very strict on phone use especially
social media
and then I started building more habits
do you think social media makes men more
feminine absolutely really yeah because
feminine is receiving energy it's
consumption energy
okay explain that more right so the
feminine so looking at male and female
okay so the guy has a penis which
penetrates right right it says outward
energy
the feminine is receiving so a lot of
guys are sitting there on social media
receiving receiving receiving receiving
receiving but you're not doing anything
with it masculine managing is doing
energy both in men and women
so what do you do once you've read all
that stuff
what do most people do with it nothing
they'll just carry on
actually I have a question okay that's
because it's made me think of something
okay because some of the femininity
coaches I see
I feel like a really full of [__]
now I don't have any basis to this I'm
not a femininity expert in fact I was a
tomboy very much so I was I was a female
athlete so
I I would like to say I have no
credibility in saying this they just
they seem full of [__] and I'll tell you
why because it's always like just do
nothing and I'm like what do you mean
just do nothing but when you say
receiving now I understand because
that's what they always say just sit and
receive
but sometimes it just seems like a
reason to be lazy
yeah so I was just I don't know if
you've any thoughts on this well the
message they get and the message I I
received was go with the flow okay
I'm like what does that mean just like
what there are times in your life where
you want to be still right yeah there
are times where you do want to receive
but the it's it's a balance rather than
an imbalance okay so a lot of guys are
becoming more the nice guy syndrome is
their passive
instead of actively going and getting
something yeah so they're more passive
they'll consume video games they'll
consume Netflix they'll cons there's a
there's a huge culture of consumption
so I started a group uh first of Jan
2020.
so I started a group with the guys and I
said look one of the things I've learned
is that to recover from you know the
nice guy syndrome recover from going
from boy to man is to become active is
to start producing and creating
that's what masculine energy does it's
all action based it's movement based
so we started with the habits and then
we started every week I would do a
master class or a connection call we
would you know connect and talk and
every week they will log how many habits
they completed and they'll log what they
achieved and what they're challenged in
I said because a lot of times you will
just consume something and do nothing
with it right right yeah so this is now
every week I'm making making you know
we're making it to the accountable and
then we do something with it it's like
what did you learn here's what I learned
how many habits did you do how many
times did you go to the gym how many
times did you write how many times did
you Journal
how many times did you contribute
towards the community
so I wanted to see that and then they
realized ah
it's even a bit too much here
so you first fixed the the mother issues
right the the attachment I know I'm
paraphrasing it
you
I work on the mother issues kind of the
last thing that was last only because
it sounded weird just quick it sounded
like that was first yeah it sounded like
because you said the attachment was that
was that's actually last that that is
lost because I don't talk about the
mother issues straight away okay so I
talk about you know soothing your
anxiety start developing your own life
start creating your own life a lot of
guys who
have divorces
breakups they crumble because they don't
have their own life
so when they don't have their own life
they don't they're lost
and that was me and I see a lot of the
guys and they're like and it's a shock
to them
so one of the things that we start to do
is start start to you know change the
narrative
reprogram how you see yourself
and then start individualizing and then
we start working more on the mum issues
because I didn't realize this but when I
was doing the mum issues
if you start to tackle a man's mum's
issue straight away or early on he will
reject it unconsciously
because there's a bind between the Son
and the mother the invisible bind and
he'll do anything to keep that bind
unconsciously so I reject it
did that happen to you at all
I think at some points it did and my car
my coach was quite understanding of it
and he said he was you know you'll have
some avoidant Tendencies come out you
will start to avoid things to start to
justify them in your head
and he said you won't lean into the that
difficult stuff
he said I'll give you some challenges
you won't do them what's a challenge
give example so for example one of the
challenges I give the guys is show up
every week
show up every single week can you honor
that can you commit to that
and 95 of the guys can't
so 95 of the guys like that's too
difficult
just to show up yeah
just to do anything consistent
okay consistency it's
keeping the word and consistency is one
of the most difficult things because
you're more in the feminine energy and
The Feminine energy goes through
emotions rather than honor and integrity
it's logical uh talk to me a little bit
more about some things like with
masculinity and femininity that the
Western world gets wrong
or even not even now the non-western
world too I guess yeah 2023 the modern
world maybe so
here's something I really learned by
screwing up right really [__] up in
relationships and seeing so many other
guys do this
the masculine leads the feminine follows
when I say this no that's not right and
you know this and you know this from the
work that you do the masking so when you
go to salsa
what is a salsa instructor say
men lead the women follow yeah so first
time I went to a salsa lesson
I remember I was there and it's my first
lessons for beginners I was there and
this other black girl was next to me
very pretty and
um she was my partner and then uh and
the instructor said right men you will
lead
women you'll follow
she just wrote her arms together looked
at me and she goes I ain't following no
man
I was like [__] I'm only here for
ourselves to listen I just I just want
it to be easy and fun yeah then I said
well hang on a minute
let's let's have some compassion because
there's obviously a reason why she's
saying that so I said to her look okay
no worries let's let's go on the side
and just uh start talking so we started
having a conversation
and
we started talking talking talking and
what happened was that she had a huge
wall up
she had a protective wall up she had
like a huge masculine wall up
and then every time I try to break that
wall it'd go higher
but then I learned in through my work
that it's okay for her to have a wall
because it's just a response to her
feeling unsafe and the feminine's desire
is to feel safe
so as we started talking and she
realized that my wall didn't come down
and then eventually after half an hour
she just let go
let me ask you this so I always hear
women say that
they need the right man to be feminine
and I have heard people that say there's
some truth to that and it sounds like
maybe you're in that camp
to me I've noticed like I think that
like fem women are either like feminine
or they're not feminine and it's like
because
I've just noticed the girls that say
that it's not it's just like they're not
feminine with anybody
and I'm like I don't think it's for the
red man I think you're just not feminine
do you think I'm wrong you think I'm
right here's how I see it I think
here's my experience okay
the feminine women are more responsive
they respond more
because what they receive will respond
to you know the question is what do
women want that's a futile questions
that's a wrong question
it's not what do women want
the better question is what do women
respond to frequently
um
so when I see what they respond to
frequently it's like when a man knows
where he's going knows what he wants
knows how to get there he's having fun
on the way what I see is that women
naturally respond in a feminine way
so to me I think there is both sides but
for for most of the guys if the guy is
decisive he knows what he wants he knows
how to get it his empathetic understands
the situation he leads over controlling
a lot of guys I noticed that are control
rather than leading and that's where I
see that that women start building up
walls
so in that example and it's I've had
many examples like that when I've been
the weak guy indecisive don't know what
I want in life I see that they build up
walls
but when I've known exactly what I want
when I've set boundaries when I've set
rules rules of engagement they kind of
like
either I like this guy
write it down or I don't yeah sometimes
they'll have their issues and they won't
submit they'll refuse to submit or
they'll refuse to
step into their their feminine yeah it's
to me submission isn't about that you
lose power submission to me is that you
choose who you so for a woman it's who
she chooses to lead or who'll lead for
her that's her power just like when you
go salsa she can choose any guy she says
she has that right to choose any guy so
in my experiment experience those women
it's like
how do I put it like maybe they could
submit for a little bit but I feel like
who you are always comes out yeah and so
the women I know that are like ball
buster you know like like they're just
they're just not feminine they're not
saying I don't doesn't mean you're a bad
person but this is just my experience
but it like to me the most feminine
women I know it doesn't matter like what
guy they're around they're just feminine
to a degree yeah yeah yeah maybe there's
some in the middle right I don't know
yeah but the real feminine women if they
if they hang around with a with a very
uh feminine guy she will naturally start
to build her masculine side up and
she'll start building oh that's an
interesting take okay yeah because what
I see is like you have your Core Essence
so what I learned was I did a lot of
things that were feminine I was really
embarrassed about it I was shameful
about it I thought oh my God I'm like
feminine from the inside
this really question he says you want to
find out your Core Essence
he said imagine you both are naked in
bed
do you want to Ravish or be ravished do
you want to be taken or do you want to
take and he says if you want to take the
person most of the time that's that's
masculine that's your masculine energy
you want to want to take the person want
to penetrate the person
what happens is he said as life goes on
as women see experienced men the first
Mendel experience is their father
and
what happens is when they start
experiencing the father and they see
some incongruency with the father he may
say you know I hate work
but he goes to work all the time
and she in her mind she's thinking why
is he going to work when he hates work
why is he doing something that he hates
why is he complaining about Mom
and still be in this relationship why is
he doing things that he hates and
doesn't want to do so she'll see this
and she'll start distrusting that part
and then she'll then carry on so it'll
be like another shell
she'll create another show so she'll
create more of a masculine shell and
then she'll see that guys are indecisive
then she'll start making decisions
guys in our leading so she'll start
leading so she'll start building the
shells up so when they go on a date they
have a strong masculine shell already
hmm
it makes a lot of sense actually
it does because you know what I've
noticed being like a female athlete I
can like tell when girls have played
Sports
like there's something just like a
little bit different about girls that
play sports I've heard it messes with
their hormones like one but two because
it's more of like a masculine
environment yeah and I think it's also
why like basketball there's so many
lesbians in basketball like let me tell
you
they would like break up on the team you
know what I mean like yeah yeah
yeah where it's like when you put women
in a more masculine environment like
they can change a bit yeah yeah this
thought
for example like if you have um two um
if you take
a masculine guy and a feminine woman and
you put them on an island and they spend
a lot of time together what will happen
is that it happens in relationships they
start to neutralize so he starts
becoming less masculine and she starts
becoming less
feminine
and when the polarity starts losing
then you become more like
friends
then lovers oh yeah tell me because
that's a huge complaint I hear that like
they became friends that like the spark
died yeah why does that happen so in
order for attraction so attraction grows
in space and attraction grows in
distinction
so the masculine has very distinct roles
that it plays in in the law of eroticism
and and so does a feminine when we start
to spend a lot of time with each other
what we do is we start to start having
um
the guys will start having more
emotional
uh conversations
and then she'll start to have more
logical conversations
and then she'll start making more
decisions about the house working my
decisions about it rather than having
this separate so when I discovered that
when I keep a separation
from
the women I see
and I have space and time
to re-energize myself with my my
masculine by being more purposeful
problem solving
you know being around guys this is a
huge thing
a lot of nice guys they're not around
other men they're not around other men
I've noticed that too I I didn't realize
how important it is for guys to have
like a group of male friends it's so
important yeah and
um like
because I grew up between two boys so
I'd always feel left out I'm like why
can't I come
but what I realized is that like if
you're it's weird like when a girl comes
to like a guy's thing it like ruins it
for guys even if I even if I'm related
to them it is like like it's just yeah
it's big men just have a different like
bond with each other than they'll ever
have with a woman
it is and when um when we do men's work
uh I have female guest speakers on
and I just see the guys change
I see them you know they're more
filtered
they watch what they say
right they're like I don't upset her
that that's what I noticed or that's
what they told me when I was at that
men's like pickup conference was there
like I'm trying not to like because
they're saying I'm trying to be
unfiltered but it's hard when you're
here it is yeah it is because you're
thinking well you know she might judge
me well mom might be upset I don't want
to see that reaction right yeah so I'll
do it hidden or I'll be secretive about
it or just deal with the guys because I
remember going on a stag do bachelor's
party and I was with like 20 other guys
The Way They Were amongst us guys was
very different as soon as they had to
check in and they had to phone their
their Partners or something it'd be very
different the tone changed how the spoke
changed and I used to I used to think
that was a bad thing like it was being
fake or something when I was younger
because I would notice it with the girls
too like yeah of course I Mean Girls
Talk different around each other than
around guys so you think it's a good
thing or a bad thing
um I think it's a good thing I don't
think you like do you think you should
maybe you could tell me if you think I'm
wrong but do you think you should talk
to a woman the way you talk to a man
no absolutely not like I don't think
women should talk to men the way we talk
to other women no no so how we talk to
each other is very different but what I
noticed was that the demeanor changed
they became quite
they became more submissive oh okay yeah
that's how they met yeah that's they
became more submissive and like yes okay
I I'm doing this and I thought wow this
is real
first they had the provado as soon as
they were talking to their partner and
they were like really submissive that
was a big thing I noticed yeah I've seen
that have you seen that I've seen a bit
I bet have you ever seen them with like
your brothers might change when maybe
they're Partners in the room but when
she's not in the room
no not not maybe my little brother when
he was younger but my brothers are kind
of the same yeah
that's that's I think because you grew
up in a a very strong family unit and I
think when you grow up in a strong
family was your dad very strong with
your mom
no not always
um I think
yeah I mean
I would say sometimes he was sometimes
he wasn't I could definitely see where
sometimes like she ran the show a bit
but I think at the end of the day it was
like his I would say his say but right
but I I like I could see some of those
issues happening at times
like for example if I was to
um have a helicopter view of of your
family it's supposed to go back
would I know who runs a show most of the
time yeah
maybe that yeah
whereas with most dysfunctional
relationships the nice guys
what I've seen is that the the woman
runs a show
and she resents it she hates it she's
like I remember my ex-wife telling my
sister this she didn't tell me directly
so she had you know she was having a
conversation with my sister after
breakup
and she said
Faisal didn't have any backbone
and he was he didn't have any backbone
he wasn't a strong man
and the funny thing is my mom complained
about the same thing about my dad
wow
so how do men can men fix it like once
they're already in a relationship
because I'd imagine it's got to be hard
if she already has the power she's used
to having the control can you can men
take it back yeah you can but it it
takes a lot of patience okay it takes a
lot of patience and the way we start is
you start with the internal world
I mean I I deal with many with single
guys single nice guys but I do have
occasionally uh married guys that come
to me and say look I really want some of
the the philosophy that ethos I can see
my codependency my me she's coming out
I'm always trying to please her what do
I do and I'm losing the traction
I always start with the self start to
put your put your wants first
stop meeting your needs and your wants
first
put that first start building what you
want in your life
because a lot of guys just want like
whatever she wants I'll do
so it's figuring out like what they want
yeah do a lot a lot of guys must not
even know what they want that's what
I've noticed even
because a lot of times like women like
they'll complain like women are so bad
and I have to admit we are but as as a
whole right we I can't like 80 of us are
overweight like with this you can't say
it's going good but but it's like on the
other hand a lot of times I'll ask guys
like what do you want in a girl and the
description they give like is so Broad
in what they want in a way if they don't
have specific things they want her to do
it's just like well I want her to be my
piece and I'm like okay well could you
go into what does that mean yeah and I
think almost like women and men will use
these like buzz terms which is kind of
like what you're supposed to say but no
one really knows what it means yeah like
the like one of the best examples I
could think of that a girl gave of like
how she's her husband's piece she's like
oh I'll take off his boots when he gets
home and like as you get all these
little details I don't remember what it
is completely now but it's like things I
don't know things that you wouldn't
normally think of yeah it's about
getting into
when I started deciding uh rather than
doing a list I kind of did a like a
story so rather than saying oh you know
she's going to have X Y and Z it was
more of a story so for example
one of the things I remember putting was
like I put a wrote a document it says my
woman and I said you know when you walk
into the room
you know people are pleasantly
um you know they feel Pleasant in your
in your company
and when you show up in a room you're
not trying trying hard to please people
you're not trying to win anyone's
approval you're not seeking attention or
validation
you show up because you care and one of
the things I put was I know that life is
going to be hard
but the you choose to be better rather
than bitter
can you explain that a little more
after breakups
I know a lot of when breakups happen and
it hits you hard
I call it like you have a blast
and when you have that blast there's a
lot of shrapnel
and we carry that shrapnel of anger
resentment bitterness
you know it should have been this way I
didn't get my needs met
and when we carry that shrapnel with us
we're going to take that to other
relationships right yeah so we're taking
all this pain that we haven't resolved
or processed or sorted out
so when I say to guys look I want to be
better rather than bitter because you
know she you know we had the dead
bedroom
right right yeah she never gave me sex
or I did so much for her I paid for this
and I did this and I never got anything
back she was she wasn't appreciative of
this
so a little guys carry this
um they're better the bitter the care is
resentment that's a typical nice guy
they carry a lot of resentment right you
know I did so much for her I got nothing
back
and what my mentor Dr Robert Glover
calls it it was covert contracts
so covert contracts are like these
expectations if I do something for you
like if I clean the house I do all the
dishes right I expect sex
you know like Hey listen I I did all of
this for you
yeah I want you to be grateful and I
want some sex
but I haven't communicated that
or haven't done anything to
build intimacy but they have an
expectation
and that expectation then runs out as
resentment bitterness
so what was the next step for you
I learned a lot about personal
development growth
and then
a friend of mine asked me to to teach
and I said I don't know how to teach I
said I I struggle with language I
struggled with with people and social
skills I'm not a public speaker so she
she struggled with language yeah English
yeah I used to my language ability was
poor
this is your first language isn't it
second oh really you don't even have an
accent yeah it's a really struggle with
language really and like write reading
and writing I really struggled I
remember when I was in 14 years old I'm
trying to read and I'm reading like a
seven-year-old
and and I and I have huge Shame about
this this is why Tech was so much easier
you know computer language is much
easier than it was speaking and
communicating my emotions my thoughts
having arguments like talking like this
now I would have not been able to done
like 10 years ago
oh wow
so then you started teaching I started
teaching
and
and your biggest thing is you do male
Improvement masculine Charisma and the
recovering Mr Nice Guy yeah because that
was you that was me and so you want to
help other guys yeah I want to help
other nice guys who struggle
with life especially when it comes to
dating and attraction because you know I
really struggle with that you know I
couldn't talk to a girl and how like
what tips do you give guys to build
attraction
so the first thing is you got to get out
the house
nice guys love uh to be safe
so they'll sit behind the computer
screen
they think that you know what if I do
everything behind the computer screen
I'm safe I have the certainty I don't
need to I can avoid rejection I can
avoid the bad emotions so I always say
to the guys listen first we're going to
do is we'll work on the mindset
and then how to reprocess some of the
things that they see
so I work on four things which is like
the nervous system
okay
uh then that's what I call the first
fracture that nice guys have
the second fracture they have the shame
fracture
and in the shame fracture they believe
that I'm not good enough
so the first one is I can't handle it so
a lot of the times that nice guys want
certainty and they get really anxious
they get nervous and all they want is a
smooth life so can you imagine when they
when a nice guy walks in at home
and he sees his partner she's upset
which is upset he gets upset so his
nervous systems are very much triggered
right
so the second one is shame so they start
to reprogram where he believes that I'm
not good enough
to start believing that you know
they think what's wrong with me
so we kind of flipped the script saying
what's right with me
we start stacking on what's right with
you
the third fracture that we work on is
the emotional fracture
and that's when they feel like they're
not enough they're unlovable
so I won't be loved as I am
no girl's Gonna Love Me
and this is where anxious attachment
starts coming in they're either anxious
attachment or avoidant
that's when they start love bombing sex
bombing you know they'll start a
relationship they'll start off amazing
really hot
a lot of sex a lot of text messages and
then boom
it's gone
so and a lot of times the the jealousy
takes over
their possessiveness takes over they're
just not relaxed in the situation in the
relationship
so that's the third fracture the fourth
fracture that they have is sexual shame
it's a sexual fracture
and in that one I fear that I won't be
pleasing enough
I won't be able to satisfy maybe she's
had better maybe maybe she's not going
to be satisfied with me and she's not
going to communicate that
you know and then the guys get
performance anxiety
and they have a lot of sexual uh
challenges with that
I can't perform
they start consuming too much porn
masturbating too much
and that starts that's their way of
trying to overcome the shame fractures
of being embarrassed of like not
pleasing at all yeah
yeah do you think
um that
um
fear is valid considering most women
have had
multiple sexual partners like most men
aren't going to get a virgin and it's
very likely that he's not the best that
she's ever had
it's it's a it's a big
Soul Point yeah yeah it is it is I
remember you know I've seen you know I
talked about body count with guys as
well and that became a real issue what I
noticed was the more feminine the guy
the less he cared about the bodycon
yeah
the more masculine he was the more he
cared about the body well or they'll
just say they don't care so they can get
laid by the way yeah that's what it is
that's what I noticed I'm like the girl
they'll like the masculine guys will say
if they say they don't care they're just
saying it because they want to like get
the girls but you see who they date and
it's not that girl
so they're just saying just for you know
it sounds good yeah yeah because they
want to get laid Yeah that's like the
pleasing Behavior yeah I'll just say as
it is and yeah it'll be okay
I didn't even think of that that's like
pleasing yeah please I don't want to
upset her you're just interesting and
women are more attracted to the guys
that just say it like it is so much even
on like on the shows we do when a girl
um there's been so many times a girl
will be arguing with a guy the whole
show and then after she'll like go home
with him yeah or try to like flirt with
I mean I don't know I'm not there I
don't know what happens but it does it
happens yeah yeah it happened to me I
was I was uh speaking at an event
and I was just talking about
I was talking about the brain and had
some kind of research up in the brain
and this girl she put her hand up and
she said no that's not true
and then I said okay
um
you know like disturb my whole talk and
I was pretty new to this and I was like
okay [__] there's a situation here how
do I handle this so I kind of calm
myself down and I said tell her okay
what we can do is we can have a
conversation afterwards
we had a conversation afterwards she was
really angry at me she was mad at me
she's like that's not true uh X Y and Z
then about 10 minutes later she calmed
down then then she said oh take my
number
no it's true it's like okay just because
she's angry doesn't mean she's not
attracted yeah yeah if anything it might
mean she's more attracted
because you stand up yeah yeah you've
got a backbone right you're an opinion
you have a boundary
so you said emotional fracture can you
because the the nervous system is that's
like the attachment with the mother
right where you're always pleasing her
so because of that you've always learned
to please women
yeah so the nervous system is where
you're just
um not grounded in yourself
okay so your emotion the nervous system
is basically your everyone else dictates
your emotions yeah the shame fracture
um
that's the I'm not good enough so it's
like low self that's more of a belief
because
shame comes from you know when humans
are the only animals that experience
shame and they go red
oh wow
like I read a lot
[Laughter]
um emotional fracture all right so
sexual shame that's I'm not the best
she's ever had being uh like watching
too much porn having shame around sex
yeah so maybe to boot so for example in
some cultures it's not okay to talk
about masturbation it's not too okay to
talk about sex I mean I've never had
this conversation with my dad you know
I've never had the sex conversation with
my dad and you know I had to learn it
from Friends the internet
because there was too embarrassed to
talk about it
I went to Catholic School
but you're
saying though I don't believe in like
that sex had in schools and stuff so I'm
like why are we gonna have strangers do
this it should be the family
well let the parents come along
yeah anyways emotional fracture could
you talk a little bit more about that
that's more about the relationship okay
so the emotional fracture is when we
I remember when I experienced a
emotional fracture I become very
very needy
very insecure
so someone who's got a strong emotional
factors become very nearly very insecure
they'll want to find out
they'll do anything they can
to bring certainty into the relationship
okay yeah and one of the things that
humans hate is uncertainty uncertainty
is needed for attraction
but for a relationship it needs
certainty which is kind of like the
opposite do you think women like
uncertainty in relationships they need
both okay because the amount of girls
uh that have been in toxic relationships
and that are in love with their toxic EX
um I can't imagine
you know the certainty didn't certainly
didn't attract them in a toxic
relationship so what what is that
so nice guys have very much about
providing certainty so they'll be very
um
obvious and predictable
and that's the last thing you want to be
when it comes to attraction
obvious predictable and they'll be very
soft they'll play it down
they want they don't want to rock the
boat
they don't want to say anything that
might offend her upset her
and they'll always stick to Safe things
safe topics safe conversations
and so it becomes very predictable for
her and uh you know and they fall into
routines very much so you know I want to
do X Y and Z they'll always keep
repeating the same palette
and um
if they're booking something like a
surprise or not more of a surprise but
they're booking something like okay
where are we going he'll share the whole
plan with her
and for for women that's really boring
is that boring yeah that is boring right
if you know everything yeah yeah you
want an element of surprise you want an
element of okay what's gonna happen
there's no element of
um
there's no element of surprise and and
unpredictability but so and so you teach
the nice guys that they need to bring
some unpredictability in a relationship
yeah and we do that we do that
I know a lot of game teaches that as
well but we do that from a purposeful
place so for example you know
a lot of nice guys are anxious about
texting so when they receive a text
message they have to reply back
I'm saying look if you're focused and
you're busy on your world rather than
focusing a lot on the relationship
because a lot of nice guys so that's
back to the external stuff yeah focusing
on external rather than internal yeah
where women more focused on external
yeah okay so if it's focus on internally
he's focused on the purpose that's so
interesting so that's why women don't
like men that like text us back
basically you always hear that like I
like that I like I have all these guys
texting me but I like the one that
doesn't like me back yeah he doesn't he
does because he's focused on the
internal yeah and so that's more of a
masculine trait right yeah because you
want something that
he's the guys who are extremely focused
they're always texting back and forth
you know I catch myself doing that as
well but when you started building the
relationship it's like there's an
element of I am busy I'm I'm focused on
my purpose I'm doing something I might
not always text back in a in a timely
fashion
so why do you teach guys about charisma
first thing is you gotta you gotta find
out what kills charisma
okay right and then when we start
removing the bad habits of what kills
Charisma then we can start saying
actually you'll become more attractive
not to everybody but to somebody you'll
be more attractive so one of the things
is is a negative mindset
complaining criticizing moaning
yeah there's nothing more unattractive
than a one a big whiner big big winers
yeah okay I know the type yeah life's
difficult oh my God who freaking it's
just it's like yeah oh my God and they
talk about oh she was horrible and XY
and said the whole victim mindset right
and they're always interested they're
always composed they're always
focus on their emotions then they are
focused on you know and people around
them
so they're more self-absorbed
one of the things I believe that is more
emotional you are
this might not sit well with a lot of
people
but more emotional you are the more
narcissistic you are
do that yeah
because you're so consuming your
emotions
but I need to feel certain things
that you forget to actually connect with
what do they need
from a purposeful place
what else do you teach them what are
their bad habits
having healthy habits okay yeah so one
things that we teach is you know
have a healthy if you are going to do
porn you know ideally we you know we
advise no porn I've given up porn for
many years
so give up things that kill your
kill your kill your energy
porn is one complaining moaning
being aimless
not focusing on
Progressive
so study more learn more teach more
rather than complain more consume more
and do nothing about it
what else
teach
other men okay yeah guide other men so
my client Jazz that you met so I've been
teaching him for uh four years oh wow so
you know he's been going through this
whole journey being incredible I mean
the challenges that he's had in his life
the traumas he's had in life it's been
incredible he's stuck to it
so one of the rules is stick to it nice
guys can dip in and out of things
stick to what they want yeah yeah
they'll stick to the and they'll finish
the project right
they're not the dabble here dabble here
dabble here do something go deep into it
and then he then he started to teach my
son
so my son's uh 15.
he's now mentoring him so the stuff that
you know I've passed on to him that he
just passes down to to my son Cameron
and and they relate better because you
know there's an age Gap he's 15 I'm 46.
so he's like Dad you know he knows more
of the music stuff he knows he knows the
stuff that I know they kind of relate
they have it like their own language
so when men then start teaching other
men how to be men
then helps them as well
wow
because that's always
criticism you get from like the online
space is like who are you to teach
especially like I see them almost like
Bully some of the self-improvement guys
because they're like oh well who are you
to teach interesting because I see the
guys teaching like becoming better men
like I can see the Improvement in them
like two or three years later yeah where
it's like even if they didn't start off
perfect like in two or three years
they're way better than they were
absolutely when you have that shame
fracture you you see you're always
seeking perfectionism because I'm not
good enough you're always seeking that
perfectionism right
and that's so true because that's always
the
that must be really common because
that's always just being in this space
on YouTube like that's always the
biggest criticism is that like nothing's
ever good enough you know and so people
will feel like if you're trying to do
better like well who are you you know
that's like the biggest oh what have you
achieved or why have you got like
perfect results in this yeah you know I
said I said to the guys like I'm no way
perfect you know I'm still on a journey
my mentors are on journey I screw up
actually you know I screw up more than
you do you know I love the saying you
know uh
Masters were once a disaster right yeah
so we keep make I make a lot of mistakes
I keep making some mistakes I'm working
through because a lot of the
the world now who's on YouTube listens
to channels like this
they've matured or they've they know so
much but they embody so little
because they don't take enough action
what percent of
your clients actually stick to it
I would say
they got the whole hog do every so I
give them homework so in between because
I'm testing them testing them testing
them
so I would say about 25 okay I was like
it can't be the majority because I I
think of it like and people will try to
run with that but I think of it like a
personal trainer what personal trainer
gets all most of their clients aren't
going to get in shape yeah because you
know doing the hard thing most people
aren't going to do that's it do the hot
thing that that's one of the most
um
ways to go from boy to man because I see
that in my son I see that in myself I
want the easy route I want the comfort
you know like like for example I say to
my son I have a rule with him so he's
been in a lot of personal development
with me and uh
when they're with me on the weekends and
uh half term
school holidays they have to do a
morning routine
so the morning routine I think is about
12 things in them and they have to like
tick and once they're done that then
they get their privileges
so I said look I will give you the
basics
like food Water Shelter but if you want
privileges you've got to really work for
it
so if you want the internet you want
your mobile phone you've got to work for
that
like in the morning and I'm going to go
back because I saw my so my son's the
rule is when my son gets up he gets
ready for school by himself now he
doesn't pick up his phone now
he said Dad I see you do that and by his
own choice yeah so I'm seeing that
because look I want to get ready and
then I'm going to check my phone I was
like yes
yes taking years but I can see it so the
next rule I have with him is that he has
to make his bed
so
if he makes his bed well and I check the
corners I'm saying this is where you
have to pay attention
and you have to do this to a high
standard nice guys just wanna just
do a mediocre job right yeah so that
would you want develop any work ethics
with this
would you raise a girl the same way
oh
I think with some things I probably
would I don't know
so I have a niece when she stays over
again they all have to follow the same
rules right because all all the rules
are to make you a better individual to
make you more empowered individual so
you can be more conscious
so when he's doing the when he's doing
his bed
and uh if he's not done
to the standard that we've talked about
agreed about I go to him in the morning
and then I put my hand out
and he knows what that means
he has to surrender his phone for 24
hours
oh wow I said because you didn't do that
I said you have to understand
consequences in life
and that's some things I think a lot of
boys are so soft in
they don't have any consequences for
anything they grew up with like soft
parents yeah and I think it's partially
the culture like I don't know why nobody
can get beat with a spoon anymore
yeah I mean it wasn't like bad hard you
know I mean I was a kid but I'm just
saying like I'd be like no
[Music]
no
so did you respond well to that though
did I respond well yeah I'd be like it
was I'll tell you the worst day for her
was when I realized it didn't hurt
because I was like No And then she hit
me and I was like oh is it this is it
but
um she didn't have to do it that much
but yeah I would say I did what is this
with like kids and temp or Tantrums
nowadays
okay this is where the nerve fracture is
um we're way oversensitive okay and and
I was that kid as well I was that that
boy and that man
way oversensitive took things personally
if things didn't go right I just whelm
up and feel this emotion it's because
we didn't go through like tough things
like right real
enduring hard stuff because our parents
you know we we grew up in a very poor
family
and a lot of the times our fam you know
mum and dad they protected us so they
took the brunt of it rather than we did
whereas my kids I'm like you know you're
gonna do your routines I know you don't
like it but you'll thank me one day
do the routines I don't do this my
friends are doing this I'm like okay
it's a certain time of the evening you
could he knows that after like eight
o'clock or nine o'clock depending on
what time he has to surrender his phone
that would be a good it
could that'd be a good habit to have and
that's the thing like if you don't do
them when you're young it's a lot harder
to do it when you're older and you know
what's interesting I think about how
it's like weird we're in society where a
lot of times even though we have a
higher standard of living our quality of
life is like lower because a lot of us
like don't know how to do like basic
things
so uh external standard of living is
higher but our internal is lower yeah
yeah which is what we talked about the
externally internal oh that's so
interesting yeah so we're focusing so
much on the external I've got to make
sure my apartment's great everything
else looks good because the status is
value I'd be liked I'll be approved I
won't be rejected
but it's the internal that matters what
do you think about so a lot of I was
here
one of the arguments is that
men are
less masculine today and are
not as maybe hard work like soft more
feminine because because of women
because they feel like
like before they might get a young
virgin and now it's like they get a
post-wall 35 you know you know what I
say like so a lot of argument is that
like the reason men don't work as hard
is because there's no women waiting for
them at the end
maybe but I don't think there's enough
uh you don't think that's it what do you
think it is I I don't think there's an I
think
I think
moms have softened
boys moms have softened boys yeah
because
you know they'll be like you know
you don't you don't need to do that
that's that's like for example in my
household with the boys I'll push them
you know I
I didn't get pushed so I pushed the guys
and I push my sons and I said to them
look okay
let's start kickboxing so once my son
started one of my son's like kickboxing
one of them started at MMA
and Mum was like oh my God they're gonna
get hit and they're gonna you know I
don't want them getting to face her I
don't know I don't want them to be in
pain
I'm like but they need to go through
these
so a lot of children are too protected
and they're too comfortable
and when you're comfortable and I
remember this quote when I was very
young
idle man's brain is a devil's workshop
when you're comfortable you'll pick and
do things that are not helpful
that's true
yeah
because what do they say like soft times
create weak men right like hard times
create strong men have you heard that
quote Yeah Yeah in your space I was like
you had to have heard the quote yeah yes
yes hard times creates from menstrual
environment good times and Good Times
great weak men well and that actually
kind of
goes back to the single motherhood like
Crisis because how is a guy supposed to
be hard when he's being raised by a
single mother yeah and in all honesty
with custody laws like the he may see
his dad six days a month
yeah it happens it happens and my oldest
son now loses me he had a lot of
struggles in his uh
uh with the stepdad so he moved in he
had PTSD OCD so he had to come and live
with me and he's
he got to a really
um
awful point
and
I don't blame his mom because we need
the family system but there's no family
system so what happened was that he
his mom wasn't strong enough
to manage a
13 year old boy
she would get scared like he's quite
strong right so she didn't have the
capacity or support to guide a boy like
that you know he's
he's going through hormones he's
changing right yeah and one of the
things that boys do
is there's a psychological reaction that
they have to Mom is that they will
actually repel mom they'll actually try
to distance themselves from Mom and I
think there's a protective mechanism
there so he doesn't go and start to have
sex with Mama
so he'll naturally separate even more
and make that distinction
wait what yeah what he doesn't the dad
doesn't want the son to have sex with no
no so I think in human evolution or
human psychology okay there's a natural
uh adaptive kind of mechanism in boys
okay so you'll you'll notice that oh
he's pulling away he's pulling away my
teenage son I you know I want to hug him
but he just like pulls away okay and you
know he doesn't want hugs anymore he
doesn't want kicks anymore he doesn't oh
and you think it's a natural protective
mechanism yeah so I I was listening to a
book on this and he was there was a
theory that the boys will develop an
adverse to mum they'll actually have a
reaction to Mom
and that's just a mechanism for him to
separate from mum
and in a Rite of Passage
like in a tribe the you know the the men
would come take the boy at 12 13 and
he'll separate him
and they wouldn't some tribes wouldn't
bring him back for years and he'll come
back as a man
I think there's a natural mechanism that
boys have when they're trying to like go
away mom um
and mums find it very difficult to
manage that
I can see that actually that totally
happened yeah yeah you see that you must
see that like mums find it really
difficult to to manage guys whereas when
my son started Living With Me
he got to a really bad point where he
was nearly suicidal he looked himself up
at mum's house for days and it was all
dark he wouldn't come out he developed
severe OCD he had washed his hands like
30 times a day he'd have like 10 showers
in a day because he had this huge
compulsion
and when he came over to me my house it
it grew me I had to really mature as a
as a dad and sort myself out even more
my nervous system
and one of the things that he said was
and it really touched me I remember him
he was a he was in bed and his duvet
pulled up and he says Dad thank you
I said what for you he said he said you
know when I'm here I feel like a
confident man
he said because you don't tolerate
the [__]
he said you know you close it off and
then you put boundaries and rules into
place
and that's what boys need boys need a
lot of guidance and a lot of rules in
place
so they can be forged into boy to man
do you have like a success story of
someone that really turned it around
yeah yeah I have many guys have turned
around what's your favorite success
story who's your you know number one
like I had yeah the one that straight
away it came to my mind was
this
that divorced
had the dead bedroom had a very
difficult wife she'd push him around all
the time he could never please her
and he went out dating and he struggled
with dating and he said you know I'm
attracting all of these women that are
not good for me like crazy women and I
said look first thing first
it's not we attract I said attraction's
got nothing to do with you not
attracting crazy women I said you're
selecting crazy women I said remember
about this you're selecting the type of
people
so as we went through the coaching
Journey
he started to battle filter better vet
the women
and then he started to see okay well
this woman is very attractive
but I know she's not good for me
so the things that we practice we learn
nice guys are terrible in two things
they're bad in ee I call them entry
point
and exit point
they don't know who
to enter with the relationship
or date with and they don't know when to
get out
like my one was the first one was a
six-year relationship I should have
gotta got out of that relationship
within months right but I stayed too
long
so that guy just learned how to better
manage himself
he stopped trying to impress women
it sort of impressing then he started to
assess women
then he started building stronger
boundaries around women
he started tolerating this of this [__]
and he started by tolerating less of his
his [__]
so he started you know
getting rid of his excuses his [__]
excuses his stories he started to work
on that and then what happened that
transpired onto the connections and then
he started dating and he didn't want to
have an exclusive relationship but he
had wonderful women that came into his
life and he had multiple relationships
and he goes this is what I want because
I've had the dead bedroom for like 15
years
and he says all I want to do now is get
out of relationship work on myself and
meet lots of women who are kind
nurturing and loving
so that was one of the one of the guys
who did really well
thank you so much for coming on
um this was actually so interesting to
it's really um interesting to learn from
like guys that actually coached men um I
think it's really valuable the work
you're doing thank you I appreciate it I
appreciate you having me
um where can the people find you
so social media so coach Faisal k
that's my handle and they can spell it
because they might not all right coach
co-a-c-h the Faisal f-a-i-s-a-o then the
K and they or they can go on my website
which is masculine.co okay
okay that's quite simple uh well thank
you so much for coming on guys make sure
you go check out um his content make
sure you like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time